you like a lot of space would you say
you're introverted even though you have
to be extrovert in terms of your career
I think generally speaking that I would
have to admit that I'm an extroverted
personality but I think anyone who is a
writer of any kind has to also concede
some sort of introverted tendencies I
like being home and I don't feel the
need to be with people all the time
maybe I don't I don't think I'm very
introverted though I'd so it's I don't
think I'm very introverted but I do like
to be by myself sometimes and just be
home and work at home or whatever so if
that means that I'm a bit of an
introvert than I would say yes but
generally i'm pretty social and
extroverted at the same time
how do you balance that because so much
of la is being that outgoing that
working type person so when you get to
that place where you want to shut off
and just be alone it's not that you
don't like people but you just want to
sort of reserve into yourself how do you
do that and still keep your friends
around you shut the phone off and that's
not the most polite thing to do the
polite thing to do to your friends you
know but I think there's this freedom
that I feel like run through my body
when I turned my phone off because
nowadays were so tired to our phones
into being on internet to being on
Twitter and it's it's lovely all of
those things and to being connected to
your friends who might call you and need
something on the phone I think that it's
okay to turn it off sometimes
and just do your own thing or get your
own work done and then go back to it
later and sometimes i give myself the
freedom to just turn the phone off
sometimes i'll leave it on when i right
but if i really want to focus i'll turn
the phone off
general yeah I think that's a paramount
importance
you